we have some things of concerns right
here obviously the consistency of the
bowel movement this guy we don't have I
mean he hasn't given a lot of detail
he's not been forthcoming with details
and then over here we know that she's an
incredible liar because we just saw her
do the whole yeah Miss pissy pants thing
and in the same way that she's actually
a sarcasm he didn't give a lot of detail
so there's not a lot of room for him to
stay well this is tough you all deserve
some credit for making us work and think
very hard my vote is for Jake I think
Jake's telling him a lot I'm you know
I'm kind of torn I'll go with Jake too
on this one
[Music]
I know